okay so let's go ahead and get started
there may be some people joining in as
we go but let's jump right in so today
we're gonna be talking about boosting
your chances of landing or remote jobs
so we'll talk about some of the pros and
the cons to working remotely as a whole
but then we'll talk about some ways that
you can stand out in ways that you can
showcase your skills in a way that's not
only going to be appealing for employers
in general but specifically for
employers who are looking for remote
employees which is fairly similar to a
regular hiring process but there are a
lot of different skills and experiences
that can really boost your chances for
landing positions that allow you to
really work from anywhere
we may also touch on a couple of things
that will assist you in working remotely
maybe not necessarily full-time maybe
your job allows you to work a little bit
flexibly but hopefully this will help
you with that as well so let's go ahead
and jump right in for those of you who
haven't had a session with me or been to
a webinar with me my name is Brett Ellis
I'm a career coach here with Udacity
I've been here since April 2019 so
coming up on a year I really enjoy this
job I enjoy getting to coach and work
with students from all around the world
it definitely helps me develop as a
professional but I have been doing this
kind of work really since I started my
career I went to school for K through 12
and higher education and really focused
my path on the career services route and
so I've been doing this type of work for
as long as I've been working full time
and the areas that I really focus on are
personal branding showcasing your impact
and building your presence on LinkedIn
those are kind of my areas of focus but
today we're gonna be talking about
remote working and luckily I've had
about a year's worth of experience doing
this so I can share any advice around
the job search or even if you have
questions related to performing well in
a remote job or just staying motivated
in and we'll talk on some of those
things I'll try my best to share my
personal experience I want you all to
hear it straight from somebody who's
doing it so I like
but very transparent and honest and so
I'll share some of my reflections as
well so what we're gonna be talking
about today is introduction we already
did that and we'll talk about some
benefits and challenges of working
remotely when I was putting this
presentation together I felt that there
was something missing I think that there
are so many news articles and headlines
talking about remote work is amazing
increase your efficiency your
productivity allow people to work
flexibly and while all of those things
are extremely beneficial
you don't oftentimes hear the downside
of working remotely and so I want to
share both the benefits and some of the
challenges so that you know what you're
getting into and you know realistically
what expectations might be for you as a
remote employee then we'll talk about
necessary skills to be competitive so if
you go if we go through this section you
feel like there are some areas for you
to improve these are gonna be some
really high level skills that recruiters
and employers look for specifically for
remote work we'll talk about how to
showcase your candidacy on your
application material so how can I better
apply for jobs or what can I put on my
resume to make me more appealing for
these types of roles versus a general
rule we'll talk about that as well we'll
talk about preparing for interviews
because there are some tips and tricks
that I have for you as it relates to
that whereas you may not necessarily be
showing up in person and so we'll talk
about that and then some just some other
things to think about and then we'll end
with a Q&A so it allow you guys a chance
to ask any questions that you might have
I will do my best to monitor the chat as
we go through so if you have questions
throughout the presentation I'll try to
get to those as they come or at least at
the end of that slide depending on how
active the chat is I may have to push
some of those questions back to the end
but if you do have them I don't want you
to feel like you have to hold on to them
to the very end if it's relevant to the
conversation and you think it might
actually assist some other students who
might have similar questions feel free
to type that in the chat and I'll try to
get to those as we continue to go
throughout the presentation so let's go
ahead and jump right in and get started
I want some more feedback from you all
so I want to hear from you and you can
put this all on the same message so I
can see it what do you think is
number one benefit and the number one
challenge to working remotely there are
different studies that have shown
different things but I want to hear from
you what you think are the biggest
challenges as well as the biggest
benefits and I'll read a couple of those
out loud
once I get those I know the experience
of working remotely has really changed
my perspective on it from before
starting a lot of these things didn't
make a whole lot of sense but then now
that I'm in the thick of it I really
understand what what some of those
challenges are specifically so benefits
no office politics that is true for the
most part there's not a whole lot of you
know it's mostly just focused on the
work there's not a whole lot of outside
aspect of it that that plays negatively
into that challenge you need to control
your time by yourself time management is
huge that's a good hint into something
that we'll be talking about a little bit
biggest benefit flexibility absolutely
challenge not to abuse yourself and work
okay that's a good one not to work too
much that's a challenge that a lot of
people don't think of no time no time
with transportation yeah so you can
completely eliminate your commute
altogether if you know some people have
to drive an hour plus to get to their
job and back that's time out of your day
that you could be spending doing other
things you can work from anywhere and a
good internet service that is gonna be
necessary absolutely there have been a
couple of times where I've done webinars
at locations that didn't have great
webinar service and we had to kind of
troubleshoot in the middle of that so
let's see what else
benefit I'm in a small town without
industry that would hire for my position
okay so that's definitely gonna be
helpful challenge is collaborating with
teammates who are in the office great
points okay no longer bus or car drives
right time management getting stuff done
connecting with people despite the
difference absolutely so a lot of people
are talking about the commute and I
think that that's becoming more and more
of an issue especially for bigger cities
or people who are not located close to
where they work remote work or
telecommuting
they will sometimes call it is a great
way to kind of get around that that
issue
somebody said reduce costs which I'm
sure is the benefit and in the culture I
would say maybe that's you might have
been talking about that a little bit
more of a challenge I think that you
know creating a culture is extremely
important from a leadership perspective
that can definitely impact the way that
you experience working remotely great so
these were all really great things that
you all mentioned if somebody just
lastly jumped in and said career growth
so I don't know that we'll talk too much
about that but I'd love to I'd love to
if if you have further questions around
that I'd love to chat about that a
little bit more in depth maybe at the
Q&A and how you feel like career growth
might be a challenge with working
remotely okay so let's jump right in
okay so this is not you know this
doesn't mean you got the right or wrong
answer this is from one study that
buffer does buffer is a company that
they've developed a social media
management digital marketing company
I've used it personally for you know
managing my Instagram pages and you can
plan things out in advance but they do a
state of the remote reporter every year
that I've seen in the last couple of
years where they update this and it
actually does change a little bit so if
you're interested feel free to check out
this report a little bit later but these
is kind of this is kind of the results
that they got from various different
people who work remotely the biggest
benefit is flexible schedules so for me
personally I love this aspect of working
remotely there are some days where I
have to go grocery shopping or go to the
doctor's appointment and it's not always
easy to go after like traditional work
hours when everybody's going to those
places and sometimes the bank is closed
or you know there's there sometimes
issues that make it difficult and so
some days I'll just go you know in at 10
a.m. or 11 a.m. and then just work a
little bit longer so it allows you to
kind of be in control of your time and
as long as you're getting your work done
there's not really too much of an issue
especially if you don't have a remote
job where you have to monitor a chat or
you have to receive phone calls and
different things like that it allows you
to be a lot more
flexible um working from any location is
very cool I personally choose to work
from home most of the time some days I
will go to a co-working space here and
sometimes I'll go to the public library
which is literally right down the street
if I just want to get out of the house
but I've also you know gone on trips to
visit friends and worked remotely at
their apartments while they were at work
during the day so you know that allows
me to kind of travel and still work
while I'm traveling and then you can see
some of the other things but some of the
major benefits they are flexible
schedule and working from any location
at least as reported from people who are
working remotely so let's talk about
challenges and struggles so somebody
mentioned this unplugging after work so
I was shocked to see this as number one
because the number two here was number
one the year before so loneliness was at
the top but now they're there a lot of
people were saying that they have issues
unplugging after work because they work
from home oftentimes you have papers
laying out next to the couch or you have
your your work documents on the coffee
table or you know you you just maybe you
didn't you're not great with time
management just yet and sometimes you do
things and have to work a little bit
longer to get things done so unplugging
after work can be a big challenge for
some people considering the fact that
you're not actually leaving a physical
location to go home sometimes that is
the same location so it can be a little
bit difficult another one that a lot of
people mentioned was collaborating in or
communication distractions at home is a
big one so we'll talk about certain
things to avoid when you answer kind of
why you want to work remotely and then
you can see some of these other things
being at a different time zone I know
somebody mentioned collaborating with
distance can be difficult this area here
is loneliness that's a really big factor
that I don't think most people think
about as they approach potentially
working remotely as I mentioned that was
at the top the year before and I would
say out of all of these this is probably
the area that I relate to most as a
remote employee especially when I work
from
you know I'm I'm talking to people all
day but it's usually coaching calls over
the phone so I'm not actually getting to
engage with people face-to-face and so
some day sometimes I will go you know
almost the entire day without actually
speaking with someone face-to-face and
for someone like me that's difficult I'm
a big extrovert and so I thrive off
being around students and so that's why
I love opportunities like this where I
get to engage with multiple students at
a time I would say if you if you could
please avoid annotating on the screen
that is could just be a little bit of a
distraction so please avoid doing that
but yeah as I was mentioning that's
probably the biggest area that I
personally see coming from you know my
personal perspective a lot of people
don't have that issue if you are going
to maybe work from a co-working space
that can sometimes ease that so you're
working around other people maybe you've
built relationships with some of those
people but just something to keep in
mind so now I want to hear from you jump
back in the chat really quickly this is
gonna be an interactive session so I
want to know what skills do you think
employers look for when hiring remote
teams so you can avoid kind of some of
those general skills for jobs in general
but what specific skills do you think
are important for remote work what do
you think are the skills that employers
are testing or checking for more than
anything else
I'd love to to see if you guys are on
the right track so somebody said
experience so relevant experience I'm
assuming communication is is a big one a
lot of people have mentioned what else
communication is probably the top one
you guys are right on it
friendliness I haven't heard that one
but I could definitely see that being a
skill that they look for especially if
your role is going to be customer facing
so if you're going to be talking with
people on a regular basis that can
definitely play a factor so I see
friendliness yes that is right kind of
with that politeness availability gotcha
self motivation I think that's a great
one organism
yes great one reliability time
management articulate these are all
really good skills so as you are
thinking about some of these skills that
are important think about yourself like
how am I able to do this how am I able
to showcase this to employers if I was
to get a question about one of these
skills or how can I better showcase this
on a resume when I'm applying for remote
roles so somebody else jumped in and
mentioned self-oriented two goals so yes
being kind of a self-starter or being
able to check your own progress and and
kind of be accountable for the work that
you're doing these are all really great
skills and we'll talk about a lot of
them so thank you all for participating
once again so let's talk about some of
the things that you all mentioned so
communication is obviously by far
probably the most important thing that
employers are looking for when it comes
to remote jobs this as we know is a very
important skill to have in general but
for working remotely there are so many
different things that go into the
communication aspect of it that make it
so much more important so as I mentioned
it's one of the most important skills
that they look for so you can pretty
much anticipate that they're going to
ask you questions related to that your
communication throughout the hiring
process is also something that you may
potentially be evaluated on I don't
think that job seekers oftentimes think
about that but the way you perform as a
job seeker or as a candidate for
position is a good indicator of how you
might perform in that job and so if an
employer is emailing you or you're you
know having phone calls and
conversations like that if you're
lacking in communication from that
perspective it may even outside of all
the questions that you're answering
maybe a technical interview outside of
all the job related things how you go
about that hiring process can also
showcase to them how good of a
communicator you are and I'm not talking
about just putting on your resume you
know great written and communic oral
communication that that doesn't really
say much you want to be able to back
that up so we'll talk about ways that
you can do that
be responsive so be quick and clear with
your responses so one of the things that
I recommend people do in general as
you're job searching is potentially have
an email that is designated specifically
for that and have those notifications on
you know I wouldn't recommend you throw
it in with another one of your email
addresses where you're getting
notifications from your online shopping
preferences and things that you're doing
for hobbies you know you want to be able
to monitor that so as soon as you get an
email or as soon as you get outreach
from an employer you see that quickly
and you can respond quickly you also
want to think about how how you are
responding when you're receiving email
communication from them or communication
through other platforms you shouldn't
want to have to go back and forth back
and forth back and forth if there are
ways for you to address things all up
front maybe it's a longer email but it
helps you get things done quicker think
about that as an option as well this is
something that I don't see people think
about very often it is the actual tools
that you use to communicate in remote
work in remote site positions so
obviously zoom is something that we use
with Udacity very frequently not just
for our webinars but sometimes for our
calls if the calling system is not
working but also just for team meetings
so zoom is a very popular tool that a
lot of companies use especially for
remote work slack is extremely helpful
and extremely beneficial with with our
team we almost do know email at all
which is I'm so grateful for uh
in in past positions my inbox has been
flooded with just things that I felt
could have been handled through like an
instant message or a quick phone call
and so being able to showcase your
ability to use something like slack and
zoom those two are really very popular
amongst remote working communities and
also even outside of remote work these
are great tools for you to learn how to
use outside just for any job that you
might be into also the Google suite so
you know where a lot of people talk
about you know I'm proficient in
Microsoft Word and Microsoft Excel we
all know that google has their own kind
of version of that as well
she's going to be used a lot more
frequently because it allows for a lot
easier collaboration you know you can go
it go in and edit the same document that
somebody else is working on you can
review things for proposals and
different things like that so Google
suite is great and then Trello is a
project management tool that some
companies use to track the progress of
some of the things that they're working
on so if you have any experience with
these types of platforms it may be
something beneficial for you to include
on a resume or talked about during an
interview so if you're sharing an
experience maybe use an experience where
you had to use one of these tools as a
way to communicate with your team that
can be really helpful and then someone
did mention this before is is experience
so past experience is working remotely
this doesn't have to be you working full
time remotely it could be you know maybe
your office allows you to work from home
once a week and you can talk about your
experience doing that and how that's
helped you be more productive or helped
you learn the skills that are necessary
to working remotely you can also share
stories of like you know when my boss
was away or maybe you took on a
leadership role when somebody was out of
the office for a week or something like
that to where it really encouraged you
to work remotely or utilize the type of
environment where you're not going to be
centrally located so maybe a work trip
or something like that where you had to
still get the work done but you were in
a different location
those can be great experiences to talk
about as well so just in general there
there are more that we're gonna go
through what these are are gonna be
really important to think about so the
next thing is teamwork and so I didn't
see this a lot in the chat because it I
think when people think about working
remotely they think of kind of being
very isolated which is part of it when
we talked about loneliness but I
personally believe that teamwork is more
important working remotely than it is
over in-person environments because you
don't have easy access to you know pop
into your co-workers office and say hey
did you get that or hey how's that
project going do you need any help I
would say that teamwork is even more
in a remote environment so think about
that as well
you know how you've contributed to teams
overall in your previous work experience
how can you showcase that I know for me
with the Udacity careers team one of the
things that I personally like to do is
as I'm working and I notice different
ways of being more efficient I'll share
those in our slack channels so if I can
find a way to send emails more quickly
or how to bookmark pages sometimes I'll
send that to the team just so that they
have a better if they're not already
familiar with these strategies they can
do it so that we can all be a little bit
more efficient in our job but think
about ways that you've done that and
helped your team improve and obviously
examples where the work is a little bit
more kind of remote ish it is going to
be more beneficial so think of some good
stories that you've had to work on teams
or work with groups
another thing is autonomy so I know that
everybody might not be familiar with
that word but basically what it means is
that you are capable of doing work
without necessarily needing someone to
always step in or somebody to tell you
exactly what you need to do you're
motivated by yourself you can take
initiative to start different projects
even if you haven't been given anything
so you know if you're great examples of
this is you know when you're in your
role
maybe you finished everything that you
needed to finish for the week on
Wednesday and you decided that you were
going to put together a proposal for a
new initiative with with your company or
something like that
um can be a really great example of
showcasing how you didn't wait for
someone else to tell you what to do you
saw an area that that could potentially
improve and you developed a strategy to
address that those can be really great
examples too and then your ability to
meet goals with little oversight so yeah
if you if you've been very independent
in some of the projects that you've
worked on maybe you've taken lead you
haven't needed many resources you don't
need your supervisor to come in and
check everything like you've really
mastered that specific area those can be
great examples to share with employers
as well so we talked about
unike ssin we talked about just past
experiences in general teamwork and
autonomy all of these are really great
examples so just something to think
about as you're preparing for interviews
or thinking about what to put on your
resume think about the skills that are
necessary first and prepare great
stories and great examples around that
we didn't talk too much about things
like time management because I think
that that's a general skill that you
should be able to showcase in general
but that's definitely something to think
about as well as some of the other
skills that people mention but these are
kind of the top ones that I've seen
employers really look for team time
management would probably be a runner up
for this list so that that's extremely
important as well because you don't kind
of sit between a certain amount of hours
and expected to get work done between
that time more often than not you're
either setting your schedule or given a
list of tasks to work on for the week
and it's kind of up to you to accomplish
those in your own time so it is a lot
more flexible but some of these skills
you need to be really good at in order
to succeed in these types of roles so
let's talk a little bit more about
application materials specifically so
one of the things that you'll want to do
is you know one thing that I like to
encourage students to do is shift away
from this kind of old-school resume
format where you just have bullet point
after bullet laughter bullet point
listing out your job responsibilities
where I've seen people have a lot more
successes when you're able to showcase
your impact working at an organization
so instead of saying I oversee the
department social media page you could
say I've increased the Instagram
following by 38 percent by creating
engaging content and conducting free
webinars or something like that as a way
to showcase how you've actually
benefited the company that's a great
strategy to utilize for resumes in
general but when we're talking about
remote positions try to think about some
of those impact statements or some of
those experiences that you've had where
you've made a great impact on your
company but also utilize some of the
skills that are necessary to perform
well in a remote work environment
so maybe you took initiative to plan
something new you had to communicate
with team members across departments or
maybe in different cities maybe you had
to communicate with vendors to get food
or something like that
but share some of those really relevant
successes in your relative in your
resume can be a great way to showcase to
them up front that you have the skills
to be successful before you even make it
to an interview round we talked about
highlighting important skills showcasing
technology proficiency is important as
well so if you do have experience
utilizing platforms like slack zoom
Google Suites Trello asana
sky all these different these different
resources that are there to help you
with communication and collaboration can
be really great to showcase there one of
the things that I think a lot of people
forget about is online courses and
especially for you all as as nano degree
students you understand the value of
taking these courses and how they can
contribute to your skill building so
don't be afraid to you know once you
finish and finish a nano degree program
to sign up for courses that teach you
better time management or teach you
skills that are relevant to remote work
so that you can include that on your
resume and talk about that when it comes
to your interview maybe you're not great
with time management so you decide to
take a two hour time management course
on a website like you to me or
Skillshare or whatever if you're asked a
question in an interview about your time
management skills you could talk about
that being an area where you noticed you
needed to improve and so you took upon
an online course to help you get better
at that
that's just one example I actually
completed an online certification
program at the end of last year around
leading remote teams I see kind of
remote working as the future and
something that's gonna continue to grow
so for me as a professional I wanted to
get a jump on things and that
certification alone may put me uh that
may have me stand out compared to the
other candidates because I've taken time
to learn how to actually lead remote
teams so think about that as well and
how you might be able to address these
situations proactively
so if if maybe communication is not an
area where you feel strong you can start
building that skillset before it's time
for you to answer those types of
questions another thing to potentially
share is your freelance work I hadn't
even realized it but basically when I
started to run my job or run my business
I was basically working remotely I had
clients from all over the country I was
helping people from back home people I
went to college with I was sending them
questionnaires that were very detailed
for them to reply back with I was having
phone calls and video chats for coaching
sessions and so that's something that
you could also talk about as well if
you've done any freelance work or any
entrepreneurial work or maybe even just
volunteering from a distance
those can be really great experiences to
showcase throughout your application
materials as well as through interviews
another note that I mentioned here is to
apply early because competition is very
high so as you all know job searching is
not fun usually it's not fun usually and
it can be very difficult and so
competition for jobs in general can be
very high but for remote positions it
can be even higher because these are
really I would call sexy jobs that
people are really looking to land now
they want the flexibility they want to
be able to work from home they want all
the benefits that come along with this
so with that comes a lot more
competition a lot more people that you
have to beat out for these roles so
making sure that you are applying as
early as possible because a lot of these
companies are moving very quickly
through that process
so let's talk a little bit about the
interview process so this is something
that I share for interviews in general
so not just necessarily focused around
remote positions but prepare stories in
advance so you some of you may have been
in an interview where they asked you a
question about a lot of times their
behavior based questions so they'll say
tell me about a time when blank or give
me a situation in which you had to blank
and so it's important for you to think
about some of these things in advance so
that you know what types of questions
they might be asking and you can prepare
stories that are closely related to what
they're looking for so you should have
relevant stories and examples around
being able to communicate well
potentially across distances or across
offices you should prepare stories about
your ability to work on a team you
should be able to prepare stories about
taking initiative and not necessarily
needing too much input from a supervisor
or from leadership these are things that
you can do in advance so that if you are
asked the questions during the interview
you already kind of have them fresh in
your mind
they shouldn't be rehearsed like it
shouldn't be word-for-word memorizing a
script but you should kind of have taken
time to plan out these responses maybe
write them down using the star method if
you're not familiar with the star method
make a note of that to look that up on
your free time we're not gonna have time
to cover that today but it's a really
helpful strategy as it relates to
interviews especially behavioral
questions that are asking you to give
them a specific example so preparing
relevant stories can be extremely
beneficial this next section I want to
talk about is like is one thing that
most people don't think of right and
definitely something that I didn't think
of when I was early on in my job search
for a remote job was being able to put
yourself in an environment that is
fitting for remote work especially if
you're in an environment where you have
if your customer facing you don't want
to have you know your pets in the
background making noise you don't want
to have you know children potentially in
the house running around and that is not
a good look from an employer's
perspective to see that
there are potential distractions to you
while you're working throughout the day
a lot of people will say when they're
asked why they want to work remotely so
they can spend more time with their
family and Wow from a human perspective
that makes sense but for a lot of people
what that really means is that their
kids could potentially be in the house
while they're working and that could
potentially be a distraction so we'll
talk about that a little bit later but
making sure that you eliminate
distractions another thing to talk about
is having good lighting especially if
you're going to be either client-facing
or customer-facing if it's not gonna be
so much that where you need to be
visibly seen then it's not as important
but if you are going to be on camera
very similar to where I am it's
important that you have good lighting
and so I have a little box light that I
that I purchased just because I knew I
was gonna be doing work like this
another thing to think about is
equipment and software so we talked
about some of those things like zoom or
Skype equipment like a headset I could
just do this without my headset but then
you might be able to hear my dryer
running or you might be able to hear the
dog outside barking or something so you
know having a headset can sometimes just
showcase to them that you're serious and
that you're prepared for this type of
role a strong internet connection is
extremely important you don't want your
employer to have to worry about calls
dropping or video chats lagging out or
your screen sharing with customers to
not succeed and so making sure that you
have a strong internet connection
wherever you go it doesn't necessarily
have to just be at your house as I
mentioned one co-working space that I've
been to before I know not to do webinars
there because it does the the
connections not always as stable and
sometimes it'll drop and so I tend to
avoid that specific location so knowing
where you're going to have a strong
connection is important and then this
last one is just I kind of jokingly say
but I'm serious Starbucks is not an
office and so if you expect to go there
and get work done every day you're
probably gonna be a little bit
distracted and that also means for you
if you are interested in remote
positions this is not a realistic
expectation for you to have for yourself
that you're just going to find a coffee
shop
to work from everyday that that makes it
very difficult for you to stay
consistent but also to eliminate
distractions that are going on
especially if you're going to be on
camera and you don't want to see people
walking by and distracting that from
that conversation or that call that you
might be having and then lastly just
preparing for common questions so one of
the things that you'll often hear is
related to some of those skills that we
talked about communication time
management autonomy teamwork but also
just questions that are related to
remote work like why do you want to work
remotely that's a very common question
that you'll get for these types of
positions regardless of the company
regardless of the position why are you
interested in working remotely that
question alone can sometimes determine
whether or not you get the job and so I
want to hear from you all I want to hear
why do you want to work remotely I saw
some of you dropped it in the chat
earlier but I'm curious to know from
others in the group why are you
interested in working remotely I like
working in my PJs I do too there some
days what I'm not feeling up to it I
don't feel like getting all the way
dressed sometimes I'll just throw on a
hoodie and sweatpants and work in those
for the rest of the day probably not an
answer that you want to give to an
employer but I definitely understand
what else why do you all want to work
remotely why did you show up for this
webinar today that should be kind of the
same answer
no traffic oh my goodness
I love being able to avoid traffic I
think you said you were in Miami and I
lived there for two years so I
definitely understand avoiding Miami
traffic especially in the rain people
can't drive in the rain um but here in
Atlanta as well the traffic is pretty
bad during certain times and so I like
to avoid that I enjoy traveled that is a
great you know personally I think that's
a great reason to want to work remotely
because if you know you can get your
work done from anywhere and maybe you
don't necessarily have the funds or the
ability to just travel where everywhere
travel anywhere without working this can
be a really great opportunity for you
community
commute is often a lot of stress for me
I'm sure especially when the buses are
not as reliable absolutely this can be a
huge time saver I save so much money on
gas I save a lot of time on you know
eliminating commutes but as I mentioned
before it also allows me to kind of run
personal errands throughout the day as
long as I'm not kind of like clocked in
and I can just flex my hours the way I
want to no distraction so that's also a
really great point so sometimes people
think working remotely you know would be
a big distraction like having the TV
there having your video games around or
or having you know your pets and
different things like that but what it
can also do is eliminate some of those
distractions that come with working in
an office there I I don't I I don't
remember being as productive when I
worked in an office environment there's
probably I probably would be able to get
like most of my work done in the first
half of the day if it wasn't for the
students that were coming into my office
and my co-workers that were jumping into
my office or you know emails that I were
that I was getting that didn't need to
be didn't need to happen or meetings
meetings that didn't need to happen and
so there can also be no distractions
with you know working remotely I've been
a freelancer for two years now and and
now I have like an office job so I mean
if you've been freelancing you have some
experience doing it so I would really
pull on that as you're interviewing I
definitely understand like you know the
differences between that and having an
office shop I'll be honest with you all
now that I have worked remotely I don't
see myself doing it full-time I think
because I thrive so much around being in
front of people and being around people
I would love to have a job that gives me
the flexibility to do it but didn't
solely have me working remotely that's
just a preference obviously I could do
it if the position was right but for me
I like interacting with people
face-to-face I don't do well sitting in
the house with a headset on all day and
so that's why I oftentimes go to a
co-working space productivity increase
no distractions absolutely like I
mentioned before I
get so much work done even just in the
early part of the day because I don't
have those things going on someone said
I don't like office jobs I get that I
can see why people might feel that way I
can also see that you know a number of
office jobs in a row that weren't
positive experiences could contribute to
that as well so I think it oftentimes
does depend on like the culture that's
built around the office environment so I
wouldn't completely rule out office jobs
but I definitely understand not liking
them less distractions yep
no traffic more productivity absolutely
no commute remote work is more effective
I agree with all of these statements
it's a great opportunity to plan and run
side projects with no listen that is a
great one
so getting to do different things while
you're kind of not necessarily bound to
an 8 to 5 schedule so there are some
times you know with my own business
where I'll have client meetings that
need to happen in the middle of the day
which wouldn't necessarily be I guess it
would probably be kind of frowned upon
in in in some work work environments
where you're doing unrelated things
during business time even if you work an
hour or later or work a couple of hours
later there can sometimes be some
negative implications that come along
with you doing things outside of work
and so I do love the flexibility of that
lack of job opportunities locally
absolutely and then oh that's tough lose
four hours of traffic for hours on
traffic every day that alone is a good
enough reason for me so okay thank you
all for sharing some of those so let's
talk a little bit more about some common
interview questions that you can kind of
prepare for we just talked about this a
little bit but this is something that
you can expect to get so one of the
things I mentioned earlier is to try and
avoid those responses that may be a
little bit more for personal gain and
try to focus more so on things like
productivity or eliminating your commute
things that are gonna help you just be a
better all-around person and so one of
the things that I would say you know
some people will say oh I want to I want
to be able to spend time with my kids at
home like that may not be a good
response to some employers for other
people they may be a little bit more
into it but to some employers that may
be seen as a distraction that you're
going to be like babysitting and working
at the same time which may not come
across very well so think about those
things
you know productivity is really good
eliminating a commute is really good
talking about being able to do other
things can depend on the company as well
there are some companies that aren't as
open to hiring people who have their own
businesses that's just the reality of
things I love the fact that you'd acity
is open to me being able to pursue other
projects I'm also part time with Udacity
so that plays into it as well but
thinking about those things in the way
that you answer the question can
somewhat determine the rest of the
interview so so have a good response for
that and be able to back it up with some
some evidence or some things that you
can maybe you say I I know that I'm more
productive when I don't have
distractions when I'm allowed to work
from home once a week I get so much more
done than when I'm in the office that
could be you know a great response right
there alone okay so let's move on we
we've really talked about this topic a
lot but let's talk about this next
question have you worked promote Li
before so this question is similar to a
lot of interview questions that you
might get where you're asked about
something and I think a lot of people
get caught up on answering the question
so literally and they think well I
haven't had a remote job before so I
haven't worked remotely and I want you
to get out of that mindset and focus
more so on being able to showcase
experiences that you have that are more
transferable so as we talked about
before maybe you're allowed to work from
home one day a week maybe you have your
own business and you've done that
remotely maybe you volunteer for an
organization that is you know across
your country you're not necessarily
centrally focused maybe you have to
communicate with people in different
countries or people in different cities
for your job on a day to day basis so
share those experiences don't don't hear
this question and think directly have I
worked a remote job before think about
experience that you can share that are
related to that this next question how
do you manage your time is a very common
question for remote positions and so you
should be able to
explain specific strategies that you use
in order to manage your time so for me
uh whether it's business whether it's
for work whether it's personal
everything goes on my calendar if it's
not on my calendar it's not likely that
I'm going to to make it or it's gonna
happen most of the time when I miss a
meeting or miss an appointment or
something like that is because it wasn't
on my calendar so I'll talk about how
how I specifically use that I also have
daily to-do lists that I create and I
put those I actually write those out on
paper because it feels really good to
cross it off um but I'll talk about that
I'll talk about how I've utilized
platforms like slack how I've utilized
project management tools like asana and
like Trello as a way to manage my time
as well as projects so think about how
you do that but make sure that you're
able to provide specific strategies
related to this and it's not just how do
you manage your time well you know I
manage it well or you you don't give
specific examples that they can cling to
when you're going through the interview
process one of the best things that you
can be is memorable it's it's it's
almost necessary that the things that
you're sharing are memorable and one of
the best ways to make yourself more
memorable is to share stories that's
just human psychology is when you tell
stories people are more likely to retain
that information and so if you can add
to that question by talking about a time
when you managed your time really well
that can just add to your credibility as
it relates to that specific question and
then as we mentioned very briefly before
your this is for interviews in general
but also for remote positions you may
you are likely to get some behavioral
questions and what I mean by behavioral
it's also called behavior based or
situation based they'll ask you for a
specific time or a specific situation
when you had to do a specific thing
that's probably going to be related to
that job so some of those questions
maybe describe a time when the boss was
away or worked with little supervision
or worked with distributed or non-local
teams and so being able to prepare
stories in advance will allow you to
perform really well in interviews where
these types of question
or ask another thing that you could do
is just Google common remote interview
questions or comments questions for
remote jobs obviously this is not a
comprehensive list but you may get other
questions that are somewhat related but
being able to have those stories
prepared it one kind of helps you so
you're not stuck and sitting there
thinking for a really long time but it's
also a great opportunity for you to
prepare some of your most impressive
examples in advance I know all of us can
probably relate to a situation where you
left an interview and you're like man I
wish I would have talked about that one
event that I put on or I really wish I
would have talked about this preparing
those stories in advance will allow you
to be able to utilize your best examples
and not necessarily have that regret of
missing out on some of those if you are
able to kind of pull them into the the
interview and so I don't want people to
get caught up on what questions am I
gonna get asked you can think about some
of those but really preparing those
stories allows you to adapt in that
situation so if somebody asked me to
describe a time when the boss was away I
could probably share an example where it
answers all three of these different
questions so once again it's better for
you to prepare the story than advance
then to be worried about all of the
questions that they're gonna ask it's
good for you to take some time to review
the job description critically and see
what questions might they ask but worry
more about the stories that you have
that are relevant to your success of
working remotely here just a couple of
other things to consider remote working
as a skill well if you've never done it
and you start doing it and you realize
that you're not good at it and it
doesn't necessarily mean that you're not
meant to work remotely um it could which
is our next point that it's not for
everybody but it is a skill that you
need to develop it's a it's a way for
you to learn how to do something
different so for me one of the things
that I would say is even a challenge of
mine is you know with Udacity I
understand that a lot of students even
some of you all English is not your
first language and I know that for me I
have a tendency to speak really quickly
and trying to help students get the most
out of their coaching
or to get the most out of webinar
content and so for me I've had to really
work on speaking more slowly with
certain students but also being on top
of my organization so for me you know we
put together proposals and that's really
helped me develop that skill in general
of just being more organized and so that
could be another thing that you talk
about when someone asks you why you want
to work remotely you can say something
like you know being being able to work
with people that aren't local has been a
challenge of mine in the past and I'm
really excited to learn the skills that
are necessary to perform well in a role
like this so that could be something
that you talk about if they ask you
about a challenge maybe not necessarily
why do you want to work remotely and
then talk about you're not great at it
maybe share a different example and then
if they ask you about a challenge you
could talk about something specific that
relates to remote working that you've
actually been trying to improve don't
just say I'm getting better at it or I'm
working on it give specific examples of
how you've done that but then yeah just
lastly it is it's not for everybody
I think that everybody can do it but I
think once you get in an experience
where you're allowed to work remotely
you'll start to see the pros and cons
for you specifically as I mentioned for
me I don't struggle too much with time
management I don't struggle too much
with collaboration or communication my
big thing is more so kind of that that
loneliness and wanting to be around
other people and wanting to work with
teammates and wanting to put on events
in person and doing those things so for
me I know that I can do it and I know
that I enjoy doing it but that I don't
want to do it completely 100% remotely
for the rest of my life so it's just
something to think about obviously
getting in and having that experience is
gonna help you better decide if it is
for you or not but it's still something
to consider if you find yourself
questioning some of these things and
maybe realizing that it's not the best
decision for you okay so now we have
exactly ten minutes so if you want to if
you have questions feel free to type
them in the chat or if you'd like you
can unmute yourself turn on your camera
we can have some real
dialogue but if you have any questions
that you know you were hoping to gain
but I didn't talk about or maybe
something I mentioned that isn't 100%
clear to you just yet feel free to ask
any of those questions that you have
right now and I'll share to my best
ability some answers and some personal
experiences okay good we have one will
the recording be available for viewing
later absolutely I made sure to record
this time but yes definitely that'll be
access accessible once the recording is
processed I'll send it to our team so
they'll upload it on YouTube so it will
be there on YouTube with the other
webinars that we've done in the past so
if you if this is your first webinar
you're not used to how the career teams
does webinars we have an entire playlist
on the Udacity YouTube page so if you
found this helpful and you want to check
out some of the other ones that we've
done I highly encourage you do that just
at least take a look even if you don't
watch any just go and see if any of
those relate to your situation and you
can watch them there very similar to
this one but yeah great question
any any other questions
feel free to drop them in the chat or
unmute your mic okay um my backdrop for
video chats is my living room should I
build some kind of blank backdrop like
you have or the living room okay so
funny enough I'm actually in my bedroom
sitting on my bed so I also don't
necessarily have an ideal place just yet
and so this is just my wall so it kind
of looks a little bit more professional
than it actually is but I would say if
you can just find something that
eliminates distractions or is a blank
wall or something like that I think that
that's okay
I think sometimes it depends on the
situation so for a lot of you if you do
get a remote job you're not going to be
customer or client facing so I don't
think that it's that extremely important
for everyone but if you have an
interview maybe just go to the public
library for that or go to a co-working
space for that or somewhere that has a
more more appropriate background because
that's okay if you do it for your
interviews but not while you're actually
working depending on the types of work
that you're gonna be doing like I said
if it's customer client-facing thank you
absolutely is there a sample resume
available for people seeking remote jobs
so unfortunately we don't have a sample
resume specifically for remote jobs I
would say that it's not too different
from the general resume advice that I
would normally give which is that your
resume should be more future focused in
terms of what is the position that I
want and how can I showcase what I've
done in the past that will appeal to
those specific needs so I wouldn't I
wouldn't have necessarily anything I
wouldn't I wouldn't probably create like
a sample or a template for that cuz I
would use the same strategies it's like
I said mostly about being able to
showcase how what you've done in the
past relates to what you want to do in
the future uh other question if we get
references of where to find and apply to
remote jobs from you that will be okay
um so there there aren't any specific
ones that I like use on a regular basis
I know of we work remotely as one
angellist is one and oftentimes the
hires remote jobs for startups I would
just I would just do a google search
there's like I said i I've not used
those to get remote jobs in the past
it's been more so through like applying
for them on LinkedIn or something like
that but I think that those are great
resources because those will show you a
lot of the companies that are heavily
remote focused and then from there you
can probably create a job search
strategy about connecting with employees
at that company but yeah I would say
there aren't any specific ones that I
absolutely go to or love so I would just
do your own research as it relates to
those job boards as I mentioned before
those jobs are gonna be extremely
competitive and so applying for those
jobs online is not going to always be
effective because you're gonna be
competing with hundreds of people so
sometimes doing your research in advance
may be looking at those websites to see
who's often hiring and then taking that
to a platform like LinkedIn to search
for their employees and try to connect
with them as a way to build
relationships with with people at the
companies that hire remotely but that's
a different topic if you want to learn
more about that you can definitely
schedule a coaching session we'll talk
about creating a strategy around
applying for specific companies but yeah
in general I would just say do do a
Google search because these it's hard
for us to provide students with specific
resources oftentimes because we speak to
a global audience so as you could see if
you join at the very beginning our
students come from all over the world
and hiring standards and expectations
are very different around the globe and
so it's hard for us to provide resources
that are universal or strategies that
work everywhere and so a lot of times
students need to be able to do that
research on their own because you know
after you're no longer a Udacity student
you need to have those skills that we're
here to teach you now so that you can be
more independent later so I would
definitely encourage you to check that
out because it depends on where you're
located as well yeah any other questions
if you already have a full
or part-time job but want to keep it for
a while does it sound good to mention it
for applications so I think it depends
on the position that you're applying for
so if you have a full-time job and
you're applying for a remote job that's
full-time that may be a little bit of a
conflict but I would say as long as it's
as long as it's not going to impact the
schedule I think that you you'll be okay
I know if I was to get a full-time job I
would love to keep this I would say I
would still keep this job with Udacity
part-time so that's one thing to mention
is like you know you don't have to do
one or the other you can have an
in-person job and work part-time
remotely maybe after hours or on
weekends but you just have to make sure
that your schedule is going to allow it
I think that you you definitely want to
mention your experience especially if
it's relevant especially if some of the
experiences that you're gonna be sharing
about is from your current position so I
think it's a case-by-case basis but the
most important thing is for you to make
sure that your schedule allows it any
risk of applying for a remote job like
personal detail going into the wrong
hands um I think that there there's
always gonna be risk with that if you
don't do your research on the back end
to kind of learn and understand that
company especially when people utilize
sites like indeed there's not a whole
lot of barrier to entry for you if you
wanted to create a job and so that's why
I usually recommend that if people are
using job search sites like that
don't put your resume or don't put your
like full address on your resume
do your research of the companies that
you're applying for because you know
really anybody for the most part can go
on those sites and create a job if that
you know if they allow it and just
collect resumes to get personal
information so don't try to put your
full address and on your resume in
general but I think that there's always
that risk and so if you do your research
upfront you should be able to decide
whether or not they're like a more
reputable company let's see I once
recorded a video conference that I was
hosting communicating some concept I was
surprised by the quirks I displayed that
I wish I hadn't I can see how practice
videochat interviews yeah um I think
that it's definitely something you get
used to when I was doing my first second
third fourth webinar I was definitely
very very nervous about the technical
the potential technical difficulties for
me I've been teaching and presenting for
as long as I've been coaching and so for
me it's nothing for me to get up and
teach something but I was worried about
how am I gonna monitor the chat what if
the connection is bad what if you know
students are screaming in the background
and I don't know how to mute them for me
it was a lot about being more
comfortable utilizing zoom and utilizing
the the technical tools for me to feel a
lot more confident like with with this
webinar I you know was ready to go
within a matter of like 10 or 15 minutes
cuz I've been doing it for a year at
this point so I definitely see your
concerns and potential worries about
that aspect of things but it as with
anything you're only gonna get better
and more confident with practice so
don't stress it it happens to all of us
especially in the early stages okay so
thank you all so much for attending I
hope this was helpful I hope you all
gained something at least learned one
thing where at least learned how to
better present yourself for these types
of roles stay active in the the careers
channels in the student hub we
oftentimes post tips each career coach
is assigned a week where they put five
different tips throughout the week we
also have our office hours or our career
hotline where we are there and present
for an entire hour out of the week and
so if you have any quick questions or
questions related to your career feel
free to drop those there but if you have
any questions in general regarding the
the careers offerings or anything that
maybe I wasn't able to touch on today
feel free to email career - support at
udacity.com they're there to assist you
with any kind of questions that we might
not be able to answer in the end the
webinar today also if you want to talk
specifically with a coach please please
schedule one-on-ones with us this is
what we are here to do we are here to
help you all intern
of your career planning and your career
goals there's only so much that we can
do in group settings there you know you
all have specific situations you all
have unique backgrounds and sometimes it
just takes you speaking directly to
somebody who has experience in the
industry to be able to put you in the
right direction so I would say schedule
career coaching sessions with us but
also please please please at least check
out that career webinars playlist all
you have to do is go to youtube and type
in Udacity go to their Channel and then
you'll see the career webinars playlist
and we've been doing these consistently
for about a year and so there's a ton of
content on there around creating a pitch
there's two that I did there on LinkedIn
there's one I did at the new year about
creating a job search strategy there are
others around avoiding procrastination
and addressing resume gaps so most of
the webinar topics that we're coming up
with are not pulled straight out of our
head these are common issues that we're
seeing from Udacity students so if I
have for coaching calls next week that
talked about the same exact thing that
we don't have a webinar about I'll
create it around that topic and so those
webinars are extremely relevant for the
issues that you'd ask these students are
experiencing so please do check those
out and they they're gonna be as helpful
as this one hopefully in in terms of
your specific situation on what you're
looking for so thank you all again for
attending as I mentioned once we're done
with this presentation it's gonna be
recorded and uploaded to that same
YouTube playlist and so if you want to
come back to it or you just enjoyed
watching me speak so much that you want
to watch it again it'll be there as well
but thank you all for attending I really
appreciate your participation through
the chats asking great questions
providing great perspectives and I hope
to see you all again soon
for our next webinar so thank you all
again